the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
strong round robin tournament and it is
a pleasure to bring you the action for a
very nice event here with one of my best
friends i'm grandmaster alejandro
ramirez with grand master christian
carrillo alejandro such a pleasure to be
back with you in the studio absolutely
and what a great initiative we have for
you it might not have the fireworks or
the glamour of the sing field cup but
these are important round robins for
upcoming players we have collegiate
players we have junior players we have
players that are barely teenagers in
this event trying to become stronger at
chess but they're already established
grandmasters christian tell us a little
bit about it this is what i love about
the st louis chess club it takes the
players all the way from the scholastic
level to the top to the u.s championship
level to the sinfield cup level and now
we also have the 25 to the 2700 level
which in the past it was a bit neglected
i love to see these players back on the
board competing against the best chess
players in the united states such a
pleasure to watch absolutely these are
some of the best in the world including
but they're still trying to reach that
elite level right they're still players
that are trying to break the 2600
barrier they're players that are trying
to break the 2700 barrier but it is
difficult to do so in open events it is
a much better battlefield for them to
practice in round robins so let's take a
look at what we have in store for you
for the next week and a half absolutely
and we're going to start with the fields
we're actually going to look at the
group a first alejandro take us through
that group a has a lot of known stars a
lot of local players as well jeffrey
chung one of the best players in america
as well as sam savion they have been
vying for the top junior spot for quite
a while none of them are juniors anymore
but they're still very very young local
players ray robson and alia nishnik as
well as dario spirits are the three four
from five of the group all of them over
26.50 feeding and we have a young rising
superstar that is hans niemann from the
united states he went last year he was
2500 all the way to 26 40 in the span of
one year that is simply brilliant we
have mikhail antipal playing under the
feeder flag we have aram hakobian a
collegiate player alex lederman and
camille dragoon from poland another
collegiate player
yeah this is a group with a lot of
collegiate players we'll be talking
about that later we actually have some
of our students in this and the b group
but let's take a look at the next one
we have robert hangoski representing
america as well as elsa and maria dibari
and christopher yu all of them very high
rated uh trying to get up there in the
ratings christopher has had a tremendous
year going from high 2400 finally
getting his grandmaster title at the
tender age of 15 and of course rising in
the rankings meanwhile two collegiate
players jj alimorandi my student that
goes to saint louis university at 25-24
and titus trabavichus from lithuania but
of course a long time student of ut
dallas and another collegiate player sam
cunning from playing under a defeated
flag and he's actually an active student
at texas tech right now chris rapka also
an active student at mizzou and
abhimanyu mishra the youngest grand
master in the world at only 12 years of
age armani mikhailian and harshit raja
another collegial player tell us a
little bit about abimani alejandro
abimanu definitely was the sensation of
last year when he broke sergey
karjakin's record to become the youngest
player to ever reach the grand master
title did it at barely over 12 years of
age which is just absolutely incredible
and these are the type of stepping
stones that these kind of players need
they need to fight against other grand
masters some of them establish some of
them uprising but it is important for
players like abi manu to measure
themselves against some uh 2500s and
2600s and let's take a look at the
schedule alejandro what do we have
let's take a look first at the format as
we have a two round robin tournaments
pretty straightforward time control we
have classic chess 90 minutes or 40
moves plus 30 seconds for uh
every move that you make and once you
reach mu 40 you get an extra 30 minutes
now players are not allowed to draw by
mutual agreement before move 40 they can
of course repeat uh three full
repetitions still will finish the game
but there will be no agreement here for
the half point it's going to be a very
competitive and combative event and
let's take a look at the schedule we
start today with round number one it
started at 1pm and every other round is
going to be at 1 pm except the last one
thursday march 10th that one is going to
start two hours earlier at 11 a.m all
times are in central time also we're
going to have playoffs if necessary
to be noted we are starting the
commentary two and a half hours after
they make their first move we got the
good stuff we're gonna go right into the
juicy bits of the game no opening bog
down we're just going to see what is the
most interesting and speaking of most
interesting let's take a look at the
bearings let's see where we start here
with group a
and already we have some amazing
matchups for you jeffrey xiong the
highest rated player in the group will
be playing against misha antipov that's
going to be a very exciting one the
rising star hans neiman facing against
ray robson established chess player alex
slenderman who used to go to webster
will be go going against his former
demon aram hakobian meanwhile other
former teammates camille dragoon who
represents poland will be playing
against former foolish player darius
fearts who now represents america also
one of my students at st louis
university finishing up his degree this
semester and i think the key match-up of
the day not only because of the strength
of the game but also because of how wild
it is at the moment will be between ilya
nizhnik and sam sevian we have them
there on camera fighting it out this was
definitely a roller coaster of a game
but before we go into the details of
that let's go and see who we have on
group b
it is ami manu mishra playing against
titus stramavichus armand mikhailyan
will be playing against sam hanin
el-shan maria body against harshid raja
in the battle of collegiate chess chris
repcka representing mizzou will be
playing against jj ali marande
representing st louis university and
finally we have the youngster
christopher yu with the black pieces
against a very active player in robert
hungaski definitely a generational clash
here as robert has played chess all over
the world recently playing even in
montevideo just two weeks ago and now is
here playing in this tournament some of
these players have traveled
just to every continent playing chess
and it shows in their expertise so
without further ado let's take a look at
that game that to me was absolutely
fascinating if christian you can take us
or through the game of ilya nishnik and
sam savion yes absolutely alejandro that
is one of the key matchups of the whole
event very very high rated players
playing against each other as early as
round number one and we have a fire
battle fury battle on the board let's
see how it started it started off with
the english quite quiet c4 e5 knight to
c3 knight to f6 knight to f3 and at this
point black made the first big big
decision of course the natural way to
continue the game is to just simply play
knight to c6 defend the pawn on e5 and
after that we're going to have a very
tense battle
white can go g3 e3 d4 a lot of ways in
which both sides can play this position
instead of that black decides to go with
this novel approach this move e4 this
has been uh touted by uh kymer vincent
especially recently in december at the
world chess championship world rapid and
blitz chess championship with quite a
decent results it looks like a blunder
because after knight to g5 well how are
you going to defend this pawn on e4 it
seems like this pawn is over extended
you can defend it with queen to e7 but
that's not going to help much because i
do have another attacker coming into the
game that queen from d1 to c2 and now
there's absolutely no way in which you
can defend the pawn on e4 the pawn is
lost your position is in complete
shambles so what can black do well
at this point he said okay you can have
my pawn i'm just simply going to build
up in the center and on the aisle he
played the move c6 now of course c6
makes a lot of sense you want to play d5
if you would have this extra tempo as
black and just connect these pawns and
that's going to be a beautiful position
for black of course white can simply
take on e4 which was played in the game
but another very interesting alternative
at this point is to just simply stop
this move at d5 with the move queen to
a4 of course you can play d5 but after c
takes d5 well unfortunately c takes d5
back is an illegal move because you're
pinned so after queen to a4 the most
typical move is the move queen to e7 now
i'm defending this pawn on e4 but right
now we see the idea behind this maneuver
queen to a4 queen to c2 attacking the
pawn on e4 and what's the reason why i
wanted this queen on e7 well first of
all this bishop on c8 is no longer
protected it doesn't look initially that
it plays a major part but after d5 i'm
just simply going to be able to take
take and now we see the action of the
queen on the c file i can play knight
takes d5 and the position is completely
lost you can take back but after queen
takes c8 you're going to lose absolutely
everything in this position and the game
is over queen to a4 was
a move that was not known uh by ilya
nishnik he immediately took this pawn on
e4 and we have this position d5 c takes
d5 c takes d5 knight to g3 and this is
what i was mentioning about both an
attack in the center but also on the
side with the move h4 i'm trying to
displace this knight from g3 very very
tense approach and of course you have to
make some space for this knight because
after h4 right now if you play a move
such as d3 a very natural move well h4
just finishes the game because the
knight doesn't have anywhere to go e4 is
protected f5 is protected everything
else is protected so he played the move
e3 h4 and now bishop to b5 this looks
like a good decision of course you're
speeding up your development as white
with tempo with a check but
unfortunately it's not that good let's
see why after knight to c6 knight to e2
immediately h3 now with the bishop on f1
the light squares around the king and
around the king's side would have been
protected right now those light squares
are not protected so white is in trouble
we see g3 and let's speed up a little
bit now we see a bit of a shuffle a
dance of the queens right now if you
might queen to e5 bishop to e7 black is
not in a hurry he's playing a long game
all he's focusing on is the light
squares
bishop to b2 king to d8 now i want to
play rook to e8 i also want to free up
this bishop to go potentially to d6 and
this queen actually is going to be in
big danger for example if you play just
castle for example after bishop to d6
your queen is trapped in the middle of
the board this is big big trouble so
that's why ilya played the move f4
creating this extra square on g5 for the
queen he would exchange the queens if
bishop d6 would be played and this would
actually be a very good position for
white with an extra pawn of course
instead of that he played the move queen
to g4 and now this is where we stand
at the moment we entered an end game
with the opposite color bishops we see
well this has petered out more or less
into a very equal position at this point
alejandro it happens very often let me
pull that board right up that
despite the big complications sometimes
in chess despite all of those
complications there are possibilities
where material gets reduced very quickly
and some of the strategical elements
left
make the game more or less dead drawn as
you can as you can mention uh christian
this bishops are of opposite colored
this means that it is very difficult for
either side to create any kind of
advantage also neither side has an extra
pawn we did see that through the
complications of knight e6's check pawn
takes c6 rook f4 this very nasty double
attack recovering the piece a very nice
find by ilya nishnik here this knight e6
pawn takes f5 rook takes rook takes and
everybody got off the board okay vacuum
cleaner came in and unfortunately this
just doesn't allow either side realistic
winning chances we expect this game to
end in a
draw with no more real play left
unfortunately and alejandro if you can
go back a couple of moves could you
explain to me this move c5 because i
have i think it has a very deep
strategical idea behind it the move c5
definitely guarantees the draw as you're
taking
two pieces off of
the game but the question is why didn't
he just
preserve if you were the pawn you can
see that this bishop on d4 is currently
attacking here on
g7 but i could move it right i could
just play the move g6 also he's not
under attack because the recon b4 is
still uh
right yes
that being said i don't have a lot of
useful moves that i can see and what i'm
starting to worry is that if the white
rooks start getting some kind of
coordination you can imagine that we're
coming to b1 the rook coming to b7 this
bishop establishing itself in a powerful
dark square that i wouldn't be worried
about how many pawns i have i wouldn't
be counting the pawns that i have i'll
be worried about the coordination that
the pieces have and you can see this
bishop on d7
really bad it's not going to go anywhere
actually it is hemmed in by its own
pawns and you can start understanding
why sam said you know what i don't want
my extra pawn i want to force the draw
immediately and i actually think that's
a very smart practical approach i do
agree with you alejandro c5 very
beautiful and right now the players are
speeding up i have a feeling we're going
to see a draw agreement reach very very
soon
let's take a look at another important
game of the round and we're going to
jump to the big group exactly that is
the game that i want to talk about the
one between robert hungaski and
christopher eu because we saw a very
tense battle in the opening let's see
what happened d4 robert started with
knight to f6 knight to f3 d5 bishop to
f4 the london this has become some sort
of a meme in the chess world if you
might everybody seems to be creating
youtube videos about the london
everybody likes to be playing the london
some people don't like it i myself
include it i'm not a big fan of the
london some people love it and we see
robert hungaski bishop to f4 bishop to
f5 c4 e6 queen to b3 now immediately
attacking this pawn on b7 knight to c6
knight to d2 of course if you take on b7
the problem is that after knight to b4
you're going to have huge difficulties
defending both against uh this move
knight to c2 but also against any sort
of look to b8 and the queen is going to
get trapped we're going to make a draw
for example rook to b8 queen takes a7
rook to a8 queen to b7 rook to b8 and
the queen doesn't have anywhere to go
that's just going to be a forced draw
force repetition as early as move six
well black definitely wants that white
not so much white is trying to play for
an advantage that's the typical way to
uh play as white also let's not forget
robert hernanski is the rating favorite
in this event with 2554.
so after knight to c6 he decides to go
knight d2 defending against the idea of
potentially knight to a4 knight takes c4
defending this pawn on c4 d takes c4 and
at this point robert had a very very
smart uh decision to make well very
difficult and a very smart move would
have been queen takes b7 instead of
queen takes c4 taking this pawn and
creating a lot of attention on the light
squares around the queen side after
knight to b4
it looks as if the knight is coming to
c2 with deadly dangers well not so much
because after rook to c1
knight to c2 is just simply going to be
met with king to d1 it loses a vital
tempo and despite the fact that this
king is
on d1 it seems like potentially he's not
going to be able to castle but after
knight to d4 well you cannot do that
because your rook on a8 is hanging and
you're simply losing the game so this
position knight to c2 wouldn't have been
i don't think this is what he missed
what robert missed because
he spent 10 minutes oops sorry about
that he spent 10 minutes at this point
when he had this decision about taking
on c4 or taking on b7 let's see what he
calculated so after queen takes p7
knight to b4 rook to c1 what i think he
missed was the idea after knight fd5 now
this defense the pawn on c7 at the same
time attacks the bishop on f4 so it's a
very nice tempo move and it looks like
black has a very decent position but
a big tactical motive right now is queen
to b5 with the idea that after c6 queen
takes c4 i'm allowing you to take my
bishop on f4 it looks like black is just
simply a piece up the problem is that
this pawn on c6 is going to fall and
there's going to be tremendous
consequences after that i'm just simply
going to attack your knight your
defender of the pawn on c6 and if you
try to move around i'm just simply going
to take you cannot defend with queen to
d7 because that queen is titled the
defense of the rook on a8 you have to go
king to e7 and after e4 now we see
black's position simply crumble
yeah and it is unfortunate that he
wasn't able to find this nice tactical
sequence because it was surprising to me
going over the game at how much trouble
he got in so quickly after taking with
the queen on c4 if we can go into that
position queen takes c4 was actually not
approved by the computer we're taking a
look at that game before we started
commentary and after the moves h6 e3 i'm
going to speed up a little bit but it
was very clear that black has finished
development by this point all of his
pieces are out the king will castle with
no problem as we did have that draw we
were expecting between ilya nizhnik and
sam savian and if we can go back to the
board black has everything they wanted
they got a good control over the center
they have very fluid development they're
going to castle without any problems and
white's the one that's actually a couple
of tempe away from doing so and it was
this one temple that really caused white
here this nice move queen d5 very
precise attacking the pawn on g2 forcing
a reaction from his opponent of course
you cannot play the move e4 because d4
is undefended but after castle instead
of just castling and i think after any
either long castle or short castle by
black black is fine but at this point
they're looking for more and they move
the pawn to e5 puts pressure on the pawn
on d4 wants to create an isolated pawn
and that's exactly what happened rook
fd1 takes knight b3
rook d8 again not allowing white to
comfortably recapture on d4 he wants to
make sure that there's going to pawn on
d4 and this just became a very
unpleasant end game to play for robert
it did surprise me that the
this collapsed very quickly for robert i
you think he would put up a lot of
resistance but the way that he did it
with especially with this move a4 giving
up the b4 square i i wasn't a big fan of
and the more
moves came on the board the clearer it
was the black's position is just
absolutely dominant the pawn of c7 is
the only weakness but it can always be
defended with knight d5 or with c6 where
the knight on b4 is going to be
defending this pawn
where this rook is the one that's going
to be causing havoc on white's position
both the g4 pawn and the e3 are
weaknesses this knight on b3 is very
very far from the action and
it seems to me that black's position is
simply superior and actually that
white's position is on the verge of
collapse yes it's true you have a
passport on d4 but you can compare the
power of the knights you can compare the
weaknesses here on the king side and of
course rook takes g4 is currently on the
board cursor for you up upon up material
up on time i just think he's going to be
cruising for a win on this one and
speaking of cruising to a win in the
matchup between mizzou and st louis
university one of the classic matchups
in collegiate chess well it didn't go my
way this time my student jamilojan ali
marandi has lost to christopher repco
christian tell us a little bit about how
that went down well we're definitely
going to take a look at that game but i
think we're going to have chris in the
studio to tell us all about uh that game
that one was a very interesting i do
want to uh look at other games as well
because one that dragged my attention
was this one
between uh lenderman and uh aram
hacobian these players used to be
teammates at webster university right
now i think alex lenderman is no longer
on the team he graduated and moved on to
other things aram jacobian still an
active student at webster and let's see
how this played out because right now it
seems like black is well pretty much in
the driver's seat it seems like he has a
very very good chance of winning this
game this would be a huge result to
start off the tournament d4
knight to f6 c4 g6 and i've seen the rm
play this type of structures with both
white and black with the move c6 follow
up with the move d5 this can be a
combination the symbiosis between a
grunfeld and a slav structure so after
c6 knight to f3 d5 bishop to g2 bishop
to g7 we exchange and we see this
position by the way this is all theory
for a very very long time knight to e5
bishop to f5 and white is having very
very difficult uh time uh finding a way
uh to an advantage in this type of
structure is extremely extremely
difficult to find that elusive advantage
e6 take on c6 and we have this position
it looks innocuous it looks like it's
just going to head into an easy draw
right for a black but actually black
wants more than just a draw he says okay
you have a big weakness on c3 i'm going
to be able to attack that i do have a
weakness as well on b5 but i'm easily
defending that with the move a6 i'm
going to be able to protect my pawns
with other pawns how are you going to
protect the pawn on c3 that is the big
question
and this is what he did he exchanged the
dark square bishop that would have been
the defender of the pawn on c3 and now
we have this position i'd really like
this move g5 um trying to go to g4 and
creating some more weaknesses on the
light squares and we have this position
right now after a lot of moves some
simplifications of course white is going
to take the a6 pawn i'm going to take
the b pawn but my pieces are more active
my rook is ready to invade your rook not
so much you can give me a check but my
king is going to go to f6 you don't have
any weaknesses to attack and this is the
big difference in this position after
rook to b4 bishop to e to defending the
second rank but this puts the bishop in
a very passive situation you're just
going to stay and wait for me to come
closer to you i'm going to potentially
play the move king to g5 maybe f6 maybe
e5 after that i'm going to break through
at some point in the center and that's
when we're going to see your weaknesses
play an important role in the assessment
of this position i see black having an
easy a path towards an advantage for a
very very
long time it's very difficult to defend
that not only from a theoretical point
of view but also the practical point of
view that you don't have a concrete plan
with the white pieces you have to be
defending the entire time that you know
that the rook is coming to this second
rank you know that f6 e5 might be an
idea and you have to defend basically
move by move
parrying your opponent's threats without
able to create any of your own speaking
of such a situation i think we should
jump to one of the key match-ups in
group a i want to see the game between
the top-rated player jeffrey shong and
misha antipov one of a very a very
talented player here that is
very soon going to be
fighting in the collegiate chess leagues
as well as he is also part of the mizzou
team
uh but this one something went very
wrong for
black in this position we can skip over
the opening and evaluate just this
position directly
you never really want to see a
configuration in which all of your
pieces are on the back rank but the king
is the one on the second rank something
clearly went wrong here for the black
side this king is way too exposed white
has the cup the pair of bishops uh
there's a lot of expansion here with the
e5 and f5 pawn and if bishop takes f5 is
not playable
i can imagine that this position is
going to be collapsing within
a few moves and the problem is starting
from the beginning of this end game
another problem forget about the time
management forget about the two bishop
advantage the problem is that jeffrey
loves to play these type of positions
this slow maneuvering positions he ha he
loves to have this type of strategical
advantages such as the two bishops and
he has this constant pressure and he's
he's a very very good player at building
that pressure up
yeah and the pressure is certainly there
it seems very difficult for black to
even find a move and but let's now not
forget about the time pressure because
he does have one minute left that is
one minute left for the remaining uh 28
moves are you kidding me
he moves in one minute i don't put his
chances 18 maybe 18 moves sorry 18 moves
i'm very i'm very good at math thank you
18 moves but still 18 moves in a minute
now you're not gonna make it
uh
yeah i i don't see this going well for
the black pieces i expect jeffrey to
pick up his first point jeffrey one of
the strongest players in the spring
classics actually won three of them
always loves to participate in this he
always says it's great practice even
when i'm 2700 to come here and play
against such players but we do have a
guest in the studio as we have the first
decisive result of the 2022 spring chess
classic with chris rapcat defeating jj
ali marandi thank you alejandro yes we
are here with uh chris rebka a student
at the university of missouri chris
first of all tell us how does it feel to
finally be back here in st louis playing
at the st lucia's club it feels great
and i was very upset two years ago and
the event got cancelled
and i'm happy to be here it's good food
here good it's high high quality
tournament good players
we have like six different types of
drinks offered for us to us for free
while we're playing it's very nice
definitely uh the saint richards club
three thing everybody like the
professional that you guys are tell us a
little bit about your uh game it seems
just a spectacular victory for you oh
thank you well i was playing an opening
that i analyzed
with our coach christian
and he thought that it's not such a good
opening but i told him that i just enjoy
playing it
and i'm happy that i proved it to today
and i think that ali marandi confused
his opening prep a bit and that helped
let's actually take a look at that game
we're going to see that on the screen
right there chris let me pull it up i
think i have it up there we go and it
must be this move h4 that you're
referring to i love how leech has
already put a devious mark on it
exactly yeah h4 i like it
it's it's not that great for white if
black knows it precisely but i feel like
white gets a small advantage everywhere
and it's an attacking position
a lot of options for both sides
right so take us to a lot a couple of
the key moments of this game we do have
kind of an unusual setup here for black
right with the early knight c6 95.
that uh if you go back to bish uh yeah
here i know that
a good move what i was worried during
the game was that he would play knight
eg4
and the idea here is that the knight
will always have either the g4 square or
the e5 square there's no way for me to
to get rid of both and
i looked at this position a while back
but i wasn't exactly sure how to play it
with white so i was worried that he'll
do this and this i i think that is one
of the best things black can do right
instead he put the bishop on g4 a more
ambitious developing move but it became
very awkward for him after bishop e2
bishop takes f3
and it feels like also this move bishop
to g4 commits to uh taking on f3 and uh
relieving the two bishops after bishop
takes f3 because if you take on f3 with
the knight then after g takes f3 you're
losing a tempo you have to retreat with
that bishop and that cannot be good for
black it feels like the move bishop g4
was basically wasted
yeah this doesn't appeal to me very much
bishop takes f3 must have confused this
openings because after g takes f3 it's
clear that f4 is coming and as chris was
mentioning it's important to have both
the e5 and g4 squares there under
control it's still possible to play this
with h5
and then i think that after bishop e3 e6
is a strong move or one of the good
moves it's a playable position i would
probably play something like king f1 or
and just a normal game but
what he did is he played e6 immediately
which i think he confused his prep
because this cannot be good after f4 h5
and it didn't seem good it seems like
black's pieces are just
too passive the knights are not putting
enough pressure in the center remember
the white has a lot of trumps here they
have
the center they have the pair of bishops
and it's clear they're going to be
castling on the on the queen side and
immediately they can even push the pawn
to h5 as chris did
breaking open that king side or
harassing the bishop that happened in
the game with the move h6
so let's go through it a little bit i
was pretty much a lila style yeah this
h5h6 it doesn't seem like that pawn is
going to be a tremendous asset much more
of a liability but it just uh
accommodated this bishop on f8
tremendously yes bishop on f8 is just
not going anywhere and actually the way
that jj played this position surprised
me a little bit the move queen f7 i
thought castling long was in the books
but he decided actually i'm gonna castle
into uh the jaws of the lion playing
bishop b7 in short castle and the lion
well he uh closed his mouth
yeah pretty much i mean after um i
wasn't expecting castle long castle
short like after castle long bishop e7 i
was thinking to maybe like play f4
immediately because that would avoid him
playing castle short but i was like no
way like castle short can be good like
i'll play king b1 and if he castle
shorts then i'll be probably happy
anyway
right which king b1 kind of forces him
to maybe castle short because
i'm slowly improving my position while
it's unclear what black can do what were
you planning on doing if he was castling
long
at this point good question um were you
going to take that pawn on a7 you know i
was gonna calculate that bishop a7 was
definitely in
in my thoughts but i don't know if it
works it might work actually a c5
c5 yes
very nice can't take with the knight
because this undefends the pawn on b6
b takes c5 is probably going to get
checkmated by bishop a6 check
and the same applies to d takes c5
actually i'm not so sure about details
i'm also not sure i would be calculating
it
after he would play cos along well i
have to say
i don't believe in this for black
at all this looks very very sketchy
perhaps after d takes c5 an interesting
move would be to go queen to a4 yeah i
like queen a4 now if you go king to c7
maybe i can even take on b6 you can take
on b6 that might work i was thinking if
bishop b5 also works oh my goodness i
think that's okay bishop b6 works yeah
that's just mate bishop b6 is just made
right let's show that line king takes
queen a6 check king c7 check again king
c8 and the bishop joins the frey
with deadly consequences yeah this is
quite lost but castling short wasn't
that good either
the rest was quite
solid a good performance i like this
pawn sacrifice just opening up more
stuff on the king side and at this point
this is just not going to be stopped you
actually want to get rid of the pawn on
h6 for free to allow your rooks to
participate in the attack so there's
very little black can do to defend and
the rest was simple for you chris just
finishing off in style
well a nice victory here with rook jade
of course distracting the rook from the
defense of the queen and and that's all
she wrote well
nice nice early victory here in the
tournament thank you yeah first rounds
are always kind of all over the place so
i'm happy to
get the victory
well chris thank you very much for uh
joining us here in the studio and good
luck in the rest of your game thank you
absolutely all right let us go back into
some of those key positions that we have
left i would like to see how much
progress christopher you has made since
we last stalked
it seems like he's still up a pawn this
knight has maneuvered to d5 to cement
this pawn on v6 and again i'm comparing
the powers of the pieces this knight on
b3 it still needs to be re-maneuvered
i'm surprised it stayed on b3 for so
long if you take a look at when this
knight came here it actually came back
on move 16
16 knight b3 and ever since then the
knight has really not done very much
it's about time to move it i think the
idea for white is to play the move
knight d2 and c4 but i don't really
believe in it this must be too slow
there's still a couple of practical
issues that black has to deal with of
course the weakness on b6 you still have
to figure out a way to coordinate your
kingside in particular the rook on g5 is
a bit on the awkward side
but if i can solve those problems i
would be very happy with my winning
chances here with black it doesn't seem
like it's going to be holdable for
robert
in this position absolutely and uh i
want to uh take you guys to an
interesting game that we were actually
discussing alejandra at the beginning
before the beginning of the broadcast
that big game a big clash between hans
niemann and ray robson in group a this
is a very tense battle and you were
mentioning this moment we see once again
this uh four nights type of uh english
setup we saw e4 in the main game of a
round number one in group a the one
between ilya nishnik and sam savian
which finished in a draw but knight to
c6 was the much more natural approach
and now we see this idea with e4 bishop
to b4 d3 we're seeing this setup with
this triangle in the center controlling
the square d5
d6 a3 bishop to c5 b4 bishop to b6 and
this has become a very popular line at
the top level i think fabiano caruana
actually is playing this both with the
white pieces and with the black pieces
he is one of the main proponents of this
setup knight to a4 it seems like uh
black is just losing the two bishops but
in fact with the position in the center
sort of closed the two bishops are not
as important oh so let's see what
happened bishop to g4 bishop to e2
bishop takes f3 exchange on f3 queen to
e7 potentially eyeing a long castle
bishop to e3 knight to d8 that's not
what he was eyeing he was eyeing a
reshuffle of the knight on c6 all the
way to e6 and potentially controlling
the square d5 with the move c6
bishop takes d4 take on d4 castle castle
and this is the big moment that we were
discussing alejandro and we saw this
move g5 which by the way is the top
engine move and i'm trying to understand
why
why is g5 the top ng movie it seems like
a very
modern chess like move right it wants to
go knight to e6 came to g7 and actually
just take more space on this side it
says to white okay your knight is
completely out of a play on a4 so you're
not going to have enough pieces to
create a dangerous attack against my
king on the king side because i have a
lot of pieces surrounding it and
defending it like a fortress i'm going
to get this knight to e6 a knight next
to the king
in this type of attacking situations is
a very good defensive piece two knights
next to the king is even better of
course and maybe potentially i'm even
going to start thinking about expanding
on the king's side and creating an
attack of my own potentially king to g7
followed by rook to h8 h5 if i manage to
get the move h5 h4 and open up the king
well who knows who's going to mate who
and uh this is exactly what black was
saying so immediately hans uh took
advantage of the fact that he still has
a superiority on the light squares with
the move bishop to g4 knight xg4 queen
takes g4 king to h8 and now we see this
expansion and blow up of the pawn
structure on the the king side with the
move f4 a very typical way
once again i'm still not sure about this
knight on a4 this is the big problem for
white if you would be able to remaneuver
it and get it let's say knight to b to
knight to d1 knight to f2 knight to g3
knight to f6 or knight to h3 knight to
f4 if you would be able to get this
knight on the king side then your
position is actually strategically
almost winning as white but let's see if
he managed together he's trying to get
there c5
eyeing this square c4 for the knight
and now we have this position knight to
g6 rook to c1 rook to c8
and i believe this is
the move this is the final move oh my
goodness what happened
c5
alejandro what do you think about this
vision i'm actually kind of shocked i
was ready for your explanation of the
strategic elements of the position i was
very happy with what you were saying and
then suddenly this move
uh c5 by ray robson pretty much
shocked me i was expecting pretty much
anything else but c5
blowing open
the position on the queen side i'm a
little
i'm a little worried about potentially
taking on c5 not caring so much about my
knight on a5 there's not an a5 has been
the bane of white's existence for the
last i don't know how many moves and if
i can solve it by either sacrificing it
or putting it on b7 and then taking off
that's exactly the point that uh hans
missed because he played the move rook
from c1 to f1 so he missed this critical
moment to take uh full control of the
position with the move knight to b7 this
is actually starting it's just winning
it's also interesting complications
right i think i have to take sure you
can take and before i take the a8 take
on c8 now i take on d6
i have to give a check because otherwise
all of my pieces are hanging right we're
knights attacking c8 queen e5 is a
threat b takes a3 i don't believe works
so
rook check let's go king g king g2
how are you going to untangle because i
have some very serious stress right now
as uh white potentially queen to a8
followed by knight through f5 that's
going to be a checkmate yeah that's
probably a bigger threat than anything
else right because you can imagine that
if b takes a3 i don't quite have the
time to pick up this piece this is a
fork picking up that queen but remember
that this pawn is still alive so the
king goes to g7 the knight takes on e5
and who's going to stop this pawn coming
down the board but as you mentioned i'm
a lot more worried about this kind of
situation can't really defend the
background with any of my pieces the
king has to go forward but i would be
shocked if after knight f5
black can survive more than a couple of
no survival here no survival here
absolutely not king f6 queen to d8
we can just go into this variation
and i think the easiest is just here and
move the knight
pretty much anywhere right
knight takes d4 i think just one oh yeah
now it takes d4 and that picks up the
queen you have to sacrifice the queen on
f4 but that's not just not nearly enough
for black
so that was a missed opportunity
apparently uh rook cf1 was played
instead doubling the rooks the logical
move but perhaps not the most tactically
sharp the move queen e7 is now played a
little bit of a consolidation move here
defending the pawn and f7 against
potential sacrifices although i could
still consider it and what happens on
knight b7 anyway i'm kind of wondering
well right now i do have already a
defender on the pawn on d6 so
potentially maybe i can just simply go
rook to a6
okay six although i'm still concerned
about
pawn takes c5 again
although i have to say this this queen
on e7 is a lot more stable than it was
on g5 you don't have rook f5 attacking
the with an extra tempo it does defend
the knight on e7 still i'm a little
worried about black's position here pawn
takes for example pawn takes c5
rook f5 attacking the knight
rook to e6 yeah i guess you have you you
do have the time to consolidate you can
see how black's pieces are more or less
coming together for the defense it was a
temple thing it's just a one-tempo
position in which if you don't grab that
initiative immediately with the move
knight b7 yes it's available next move
but it's nowhere near as dangerous and
by the way even more crafty maybe
instead of rook to e6 to just simply go
f6 yeah i was just thinking about that
the rook is actually doing a tremendous
job stopping the night from coming back
into play with knight a5 your knight is
strapped right now it's funny how bad
this knight has been the entire game
right so it makes sense like the one
moment you had to really activate it as
powerfully as hans had here after the
move c5 that was the key that was the
stroke that he needed to
really ruin black's position but he
missed it and just on time the move he
played fast by the way i think let's see
yeah they're from 16 minutes to 15 and
45 seconds so he only thought they were
gaining an additional 30 seconds per
move he only thought for less than a
minute
a strange decision to me because ray is
the one that's in time pressure as usual
of course him being great rob soon being
in time pressure every single game
he only has six minutes left for you
know still seven eight moves to reach
time control
and it seemed like a more experienced
player of course hans very very young
would have sat down here and tried to
figure out how to create the most amount
of complications but currently the way
that he did it it doesn't seem like it
poses right the most amount of trouble
i'm still a little worried about black's
position i'm not gonna lie but it will
all boil down to the next couple of
moves because
if he doesn't find a good big initiative
as you mentioned christian this knight
of b7 is stranded it would have to go
back to a5 the powers between the
knights is are quite obvious and
remember black does have these powerful
central pawns if in some case down the
road i'm able to push them forward it is
a long-term strategical advantage of
course it's difficult to imagine doing
so right now with the knight on with the
queen on d5 and the double rooks on the
f-file but those can be traded off at
some point you still have to be careful
and alejandro i've been looking at the
position a little bit with the engine
and in fact white is still completely
dominating this game after the move rook
to a6 i believe we do have uh this
position on the board knight to b7
finally was played by hans uh i don't
think ray has played rook a6 yet but it
seems like this he just did it he just
he just played rook to a6 and now most
likely we're going to see a continuation
of the assault on the pawn on d6 with
the move rook to f6 i'm not going to
take on c5 i'm not going to allow this
rook to become active and become a
tremendous defensive piece supporting
this move f6 i'm going to put my rook on
f6
and now it's completely over because i
have so many threats not only that this
d6 pawn is hanging but i also have the
idea of knight takes c5 now we see the
weakness of the rook on a6 this rook on
f6 pins the pawn on d6 you're not going
to be able to recapture with the pawn
the rook on a6 is going to be lost so if
hans finds this move rook to f6 well it
seems like it's all she wrote i like
that concept that it's not releasing the
tension we talk a lot about this a lot
in chess this concept of if you have two
pawns that are in tension you should
only capture your opponent's pawn if it
brings you an immediate benefit and the
reason that we are so attracted in this
position after rook a6 to take on c5 is
because it destabilizes this knight on
e5 so you want that benefit to
destabilize the knight but unfortunately
i don't have enough pieces after rook f5
to really take advantage of it so
reverse the equation put the rook on f6
first i even think the move rook f5
first might also be very dangerous but
rook f6 the moment you spot it is very
compelling everything is coming crashing
down on the sixth rank
yeah
the knight on b7 joins the phrase
successfully knight takes d6 is a huge
threat pawn takes c5 is a huge threat
black has no activity
this looks like it will be the second
decisive game of the day a nice victory
by hans leeman he's had a tremendous
year and certainly he is proving why
new haircut over there he is searching
yes and he does have a new haircut i i i
went upstairs yeah and i tried to kind
of get a feeling of how these players
are feeling what the tension feels like
in the playing hall and i could barely
recognize huh i actually didn't
recognize him at all i will be honest i
went upstairs and i thought who is this
downstairs he did have all this like
bunch of curls the way i do and it was
very difficult to recognize him he
looked at the camera maybe he knows that
we're talking about him yeah well he
feels he knows right he feels it's his
chance he has this move rook f6 he has
the move rook f5 he's trying to figure
out which one is stronger but he
certainly has that intuitive sense that
something is off about black's position
and he could take advantage of it
well well that's late let's let hans
neiman think here in this position as we
do have a special guest with us in the
studio somebody that certainly follows
all of these tournaments quite closely
we have a grand master fabiano caruana
thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with grandmaster fabiano caruana one of
the best chess players on the planet
fabi welcome back to st louis tell us a
little bit about your last few months
yeah i've been out of town for a while
so it's pretty much my like my third day
back in st louis and uh in time for this
tournament it's uh it's good to see that
chess is um
is coming back to over the board and uh
there's more and more events and
um this is incredibly strong tournament
actually i was i was surprised to see
just how many um
really strong players there are tell us
a little bit about uh that back when you
were 25 2600 did you have this type of
opportunities of closed events competing
against the best chess players around
your rating
um
no where were those opportunities it was
mostly open events um that i played when
i was around that level even up to 2 700
mostly mostly open tournaments i played
a lot of tournaments in spain
um
i had like some close tournaments there
was this uh i think they still exist
this um series of tournaments that went
every
every month in hungary first saturday
tournaments right they were they were
closed events um but not not nearly at
this level they were maybe between 23 to
2 500 most players so maybe average
rating 2400
um this level of tournaments like
average of 26 26 many players 2650 even
close to 2700
uh is is actually incredibly rare you
traditionally you have that
those uh you know open tournaments and
then the super tournament super elite
events yeah which are 27 50 plus let's
say so this uh this is actually a
somewhat neglected area in chess um
players of this level that they're
professionals they're very strong but
they uh
someone get overlooked in in terms of
opportunities of being able to play and
improve because these are type events
which help these players
uh improve their chess we are very happy
to see the classics return to the saint
louis chess club you're mentioning that
there's a lot of talent in these two
fields which player caught your eyes
uh
it's hard to say because a lot of
players i i know pretty well i've played
a lot of them many times like uh a lot
are quite established like let's say
jeffrey is one of the top players in the
united states he's a very established
player and sam savion was
tied for first in the last u.s
championship and
uh
didn't win on on
in the playoff but
still he's incredibly strong too
um hans neiman is a slightly newer name
i i got a chance to see his games more
recently and he's obviously very
talented and i suspect he'll at some
point make that push to 2700 but he's
he's not quite as established
established as some of the other guys
but yeah there's a lot of um well he was
2 500 last year yeah yeah he's moving
super fast up the up the ranks uh
but yeah there's a lot of
a lot of very talented players some
more up up and coming some who are a bit
more established in the scene well since
we have you in the studio we're going to
have to take advantage of that and use
you what game should we go to
oh well the game you have up is actually
pretty
pretty interesting i don't know if
that's a live position that is the live
position actually rook f6 was played
after we can go forward a couple of
moves let me bring it up just one second
uh you lost it somehow
not this one
this one is over
why can't i find it i'm pulling out here
very interesting one as that one is
interesting as well but i'm
missing the hans neiman game for some
reason from my
you can pull it up christian first
absolutely yes so we do have this
position right now on the board i think
queen to e7 was played by the way
um the it seems like maybe the only way
to defend this position was to spot this
ridiculous tactic with rook to a7 and if
you go knight to b7 now i have this move
knight to f3
oh but a7 is a really weird movie
because at least good luck g6 hanging
it's not even knight b7 but it just
leaves d6 hanging which i guess rooting
idt3 is such an important resource
uh because once white black's queen gets
to e3 he has so many checks
um yeah or work of some queen three
suddenly
we're already it seems looking at sort
of yeah maybe even queen six years ago
26 okay so it's uh
this is probably okay but yeah rook is
seven is uh is a really surprising move
so
actually rookie seven probably was
missed by both players because we did
see hans very confidently very quickly
played this move rook c f1 probably not
spotting rook a7 if that's the only
defense you can completely understand
why he thought he was com in the
driver's seat the move queen e7 trying
to solidify the entire game it came down
but it's just not enough knight b7 rook
a6 rook f6 on the board and ray down to
two and a half minutes for the remaining
seven moves
that's going to be a very tall order but
i objectively this position might just
be completely lost yeah he might try to
maybe because he has to defend d6 once
that falls it's all over and if he plays
oh he took on b4 but now knight d6 let's
take a look 1966 because it also
threatens
well the rook then the pawn f7 even some
somewhere queen e5
uh could be in it although you have to
be careful there because then black's
pawns in the end game could get rolling
so if i just simply go rook to d8 now
rook to d8 um
here i think i do take on wait if i
let's point out that if i take on e5
there's also the important
fact that
after the move king g7
this rook's actually under attack uh
after work to d8 yeah this one this one
is
is
not what white wants it
after yeah maybe knight f7 in fact
because i'm in check black should play
knight takes f7 right now i'll take with
the rook
here yeah you probably want to trade
queens otherwise you'll get mated uh so
rook d5 rookie 7 and you pick up b4 like
rook d8 is forced you pick up before you
just have two pawns and rook f7 is
coming
so this might clean it up very
comfortably that is resigns
um but there there's likely also other
other ways to finish it off
so let's see if it goes knight takes d6
how does black defend at this point he
might not right yeah that's the only
thing
maybe rook takes d6 and just say okay
i'm going to give you the exchange and
potentially take on a3 and maybe i'll do
something with those two connected
passers this is probably the right way
but after b takes a3 or d6ba3 queen d4
you um
well your pawns are not moving so
quickly
so let's go
if i go a2 you go row k6 yeah probably
just for k6 yeah this guy i think white
keeps control here very very well
there's still rook d8 and there's some
mess but you know unless black is
promoting that pawn it's going to be
winning for white can try for some rook
c2 business no probably too slow right
rook c2 maybe uh can i play rook f7 i
don't want to
yeah this is a bit of a disaster right
that's all shiro let me just put this on
the board that here i'm going to follow
it up with rook a8 that's a back rank no
matter if you go to king j8 or queen g7
you're going to lose the game because
actually let's keep going queen to f8 ah
you have queen to g5 yeah here queen g5
gg5
just don't take the queen immediately
then you might have
might have ruined it yeah yes but this
wins the queen and that's that's it yeah
that's game over how much time does hans
have han still has uh six minutes to
figure out what's going on in the
position six minutes and 10 seconds so
he does have the time to think about
things and as we mentioned it's not
necessarily the only way to
increase the advantage i'm also
wondering if you could just take back
the pawn on b4 it's probably not the
cleanest
but it does ask some
so if you take on b4 my guess is that he
just simply wants to go maybe rook a1
some sort of tactics like that
okay one of course using the fact that
the rook is overloaded defending the
first rank and
the
rook on f6
you know i start looking at this i think
maybe i'm winning anyway
but
why go into it right it starts to get
messy i mean maybe you can still play
rook a1 queen f6 and knight d6
and then black has to play knight to f3
check because there's queen e5 tactics
yeah so knight f3 king h1
and
it's hard to say because white's king is
also potentially animating that you know
after like rook c2
uh on the other hand maybe
maybe white wins um after rook e8
but yeah it's it gets very tricky this
is how you this is how you don't win you
met because king king g6 and the king or
even king h6 and the king has
no more why can't give any more checks
to the king and black actually wins this
i think
um that's checkmate that's difficult to
stop checkmate
so so yeah this is how you uh
potentially spoil winning positions you
still have rook to a2 but
uh you're probably going to get
checkmated after yeah
well your king on f2 is maybe safe
here although even the move queen c6
looks or queen queen c6 yeah or queen g5
it's hard to say no queen g5 allows
queen a6 so
queen c6 seems very potent yeah but we
don't expect any of this i think the
moment you start to see that it gets
messy you just switch to the other
variation remember that hans doesn't
have that much time himself now
currently only at 4 minutes and 15
seconds he does have to make a decision
um
that will give him the
cleanest way
to win this game
well he's quite a good
blitz player uh i think he
sort of specializes in fast time
controls because he's he's so um
i've seen him play so much online chess
so he's probably not too worried about
the
the lack of time here but you never know
i mean even the
the best players can
can panic when when they're low on time
and and blunder i mean especially here
it's easy to blunder um
easy to to miss some small tactic and
the game the
entire evaluation reverses itself
i think we're going to stay here for a
little bit as it is the most exciting
game on both players going down to the
wire has keeps burning time certainly
making his fans nervous
is what is there else to think knight
takes d6 eight takes before seem like
the only choices to me
it feels like that is the critical line
that he's calculating just that uh
and he just took it back he actually
played it he just took back it didn't
play with knight takes d6 we didn't
really see uh the exact problem with
knight takes d6 we thought he was
winning and after pawn takes before ray
and he's a crafty player i've had the
terrible experience of playing ray
robson when he's in time control
and it's just like he finds every
resource to keep himself afloat doesn't
matter that he's down to 30 seconds and
let's see if he finds speaking of
resources alejandro we were mentioning
the move rook to c1 but check this line
out rook to c2
c2 immediately now the big threat
is that if you take on d6 with the
knight i'm actually going to be able to
take on f6 with the queen
very tricky very very very tricky
let's show it on the board we got check
here this is the background check if
except for the rook but this knight f3
kicks out the king and then i'll have a
pleasant choice between rook takes f1 or
rook takes h2 checkmate that is not
going to be good
rook c1 or c2 both of them were worked
to c1 and rook to c2 we were mentioning
rook to a1 he played rook to c2 and he
played rook c2
oh man i see rook c2 and i'm starting to
get nervous
so another question is can white if
queen takes d4 then black will switch
the idea in player i think rook to a2
because that's the second idea of rook
c2
um even if the a1 square is covered
black still has this very dangerous
looking like let's say maybe white still
has rook six to f2
but uh do i have a
no there's a beak
queen to f6 is actually maybe nicer
that's a brilliant move let's just
explain it to the viewers rick takes f6
cannot be played because check check the
other rook will come with checkmate to
g2
and if you take my rook and this comes
crashing down knight f3 check i'll take
the queen with check on the next move as
well
and yeah this looks this is not i mean
there's still okay right yeah king h1
night but we're already talking about
black trying to win rather than white
trying to win yes absolutely especially
as always with this terrible knight on
b7 this end game looks more promising
for black than for white after i take on
d3
yes so yeah now we could see any result
they're both low on time and they still
have six moves to make so six moves to
make it's not easy gonna get tense easy
for white to lose this one as well
absolutely
so if not rook six f2 what else do we
have on in store here for white we saw
knight takes d6 loses to queen takes f6
i think that is pretty clear right
because rook takes d6
rook takes d6 when rook a2 it doesn't
really solve this issue because rook d8
king g7
is uh yeah it's not leading anywhere
yeah as usual if the knight could
teleport to f5 but yeah but this knight
does has been out of play for so long
all right rotate this doesn't quite work
well one thing i can do is maybe just
plug that a5 with the move knight to a5
oh just not allow your rook to get uh
to double up on the second rank
yeah that's that's a nice move that is a
very nice move the knight
from useless to hero making sure that
the rook doesn't penetrate either on a1
or a2 but now there's no more threat
there's no more rook takes d6 coming my
knight on e5 is stable
that's funny there's there's queen
defense
that's right right d4 so maybe i have to
try to
and i think he's going for it i think
yeah there's nothing else on that side
of the board right
uh i don't think so i also don't see
another option once you see the rook 6f2
mine run into problems
knight a5 yeah i think it has to be
knight a5 and he's down to his last
minute it's also 95 is a sort of move
which
kind of negates the possibility that you
lose because white seems relatively safe
there while if you allow the other rook
into the attack with rook a2 or rook a1
potentially then you're very much
risking losing the game so knight a5
and it also besides queen e4 it also
threatens queen b5 which is an important
pawn as well oh but he's actually
changed his mind he was reaching for the
knight but he did go with the move rook
6f2 will
rey who is known
on his chest.com puzzle sprees as spicy
caterpillar one of the best puzzle rush
solvers in the world will he spot the
move queen f6 no it wasn't here it was
queen d4 rookie 2 rook uh six of two
queen of six we need the rooks doubled
oh we need the rooms double first sorry
my baby is actually playing here maybe
you're okay too maybe that's that's a
good question what do you do after okay
then rook c2 and knight d6 i don't see
the attack anymore
let's put that on the board here queen
two
uh six takes
queen takes d6 and now there's queen e5
on top so yeah this does looks pretty
bad and queen a8 knight five i mean
black can just take on f2 that looks the
most reasonable option because then
you'll get your other rook in
potentially with check
white has to take with the rook and he
took it we see that exchange happening
right now all right a1 looks like a move
certainly
yeah now it's so concrete um
how does this procedure k1 check for
sure right okay i don't know about that
for sure
king g2
would really like to take knight d3 or
knight g4 but they both run into queen
well what if i take on d3 first
oh let's start with knight takes d3
you're saying
yeah what about rook f7 here i was
wondering that is the big question do i
have enough checks to create any sort of
danger for your king so let's say check
yeah king g2 check again with oh rook a2
doesn't work because the queen is
defending actually maybe it does work
huh maybe yeah queen
queen e4
h3 now rook f3 runs into 91 91 let's put
let's put that out even this is not the
end of the variation right you give this
check you'd like to block with the rook
but knight e1 check picks at least some
material up you are king to h3 anything
this is actually surprisingly no checks
the queen defense e6 the rook defense f5
the knight can't
doesn't have access to these squares and
that would be the end of the game so
instead of rookie rook a2 black must
have something
must have something better so yeah rook
i won't check king g2
um
robson down to his last 45 seconds
probably you actually don't have many
viable moves because well there's too
many threats queen d4 and rook f8
potentially
and by the way i think he played the
best move in the position he played king
to g8
wow oh i like this every time that queen
takes d4 it never pins the knight
you cannot take on d4 of course right
now because queen takes p7 is on top
so so you have to lose a tempo with
knight d this threatens knight d3 now
that's why he defended both d4 and
well defended f7 and indirectly defended
d4 because it's no longer checked so
knight a5 allows an id3 and black is
yeah i don't know
what the valuation is but it suddenly
looks a lot safer black can even just
move the knight back to e5 next and and
well i can even start thinking of this
move of course i was thinking about 65
yeah c2 is kind of uh or maybe knight c6
right and then uh
95
95 just to defend
here on c6
uh doesn't allow the knight the knight
in because okay you can take b5 but then
you have to deal with that potentially
that past d-pawn maybe not immediately
but maybe queen to a7 and then d3 would
check and
uh it's very double-edged it's still a
three result game here yeah for sure
white is white is risking as well
so what if we go maybe knight c6 after
knight takes d3 so knight to a5 knight
63 knight c6
and if take take on f2 black is probably
yeah yeah yeah this is a riskless
position i don't know how often i win it
but i think i will queen maybe queen g5
even oh queenie oh queen g5 much
stronger yeah the same idea defend upon
b5 but instead of defending the pawn
passively with queen e5 you have this
queen e3 massive threat yeah it's either
a drawer or or black is pretty good
yeah so let's see what happened knight
a5 on the board indeed we are expecting
the move knight takes d3 we don't really
see anything wrong with it and a pawn is
a pawn
it's a pretty good pawn too
yeah it's an automatic move i think
right and it's been played knight takes
d3
question is what does hans have planned
here is a queen to b5 a move or
queen b5 might be a move
uh i mean the thing is yeah black is no
longer worse for sure after knight of
two queen a6 but is he
better
is um hard to say
and it might be um kind of drawish
eventually
because white has queen ca queen g all
sorts of checks
and uh okay why is king is weak but so
is blacks
yeah queen b5 might be interesting he
actually played your first instinct of
the move uh knight takes e3 rook c2
bringing the rook into the game it
doesn't feel like it has any decisive
threats right now but it is very logical
to try to harass this king with the move
rook c8
so the idea being that if you take on b4
i'm just simply going to pick up all
your pieces off the roof to see but you
can do this actually
because you have queen e5 okay and then
queen a1
and um
then the question is which king is
weaker because king g2 rook a5
um
and of queen d6 there's rook a
rook a2 and queen f1 and
it feels like you get checkmate it feels
like black gets here
faster it's a bit difficult to say
because
f1 king g4
but yeah
yeah it feels like it should be
challenging h5 you go king g5 but then
it's five six right so this is just
checkmate here f6 king takes you have to
go to the edge file and then there's
that queen queen of three or well queen
is made in one yeah
[Laughter]
all right so rook c2 on the board what
is the time situation right now i see
six seconds for ray robson and he played
knight e5 he did not take at the pawn on
b4 all right this is i think a more
practical approach when you're running
out of time also because knight before
loud works here in queen b5
and black's pieces are extremely the 95
is just perfect the knight on b4 i love
this knight i love this knight and look
at that expression rook c8 check finally
an easy move here for ray robson king g7
played uh immediately
and i think you have to take this pawn
right
i don't see
or queen b5 it's um he took it he took
the contour right taking
you know you also have to be worried
that you just black sacks that rook like
queen g5 and just mates without that
direct right yeah uh so
taking on d4 at least you pin the knight
you're kind of happy about that
so let's unpin the knight with queen f6
yeah and maybe uh maybe queen f2
although even here i can now i can just
simply take and go knight d3 right
that's an extra pawn yeah no that's
actually probably a winning end game
right picks up that one that's kind of
ugly
so so yeah maybe king g2 after queen six
really
yeah at least like to give a check you
have to
you have to uh to re-pin your knight
with black so king g1
but you're
well yeah so king h3 queen g4 just loses
the rook yeah important to point that
out yeah this looks so risky for white
yeah i'm not a not a huge fan of the
move king g2
but maybe you have to do it right what
else can you do here you have you have
like queen c3 you have a bunch of moves
but none of them look super appealing
queen f6 was played yeah so we're going
to find out i think this is the last yes
they made time control control ray
robson is
out
he he's going to the restroom splash
some water into uh on his face
just take a breather wow what a time
scramble we had but it did seem like
both players
avoiding the riskier situations i can
imagine why as some of them just ended
up absolutely lost
for
both sides but here after the move queen
d4
queen f6
instinctively i like black it just feels
that the knight on a5 is so far away
from the action i understand that it's
blocking my own rook
but if i can never get it into the game
that's just going to be all she wrote
the 95 is such a monster
yeah this is fully a two result game
um queen c3 queen e3 yeah white white is
probably not losing or anything yet but
it could could become losing at some
point well we've dedicated enough time
to this game they have reached time
control of course after this event uh
hans will probably take a long time to
consider his options make sure that he
defends appropriately
christian you have any updates any games
that you want to see that we haven't
really been able to look at well first
of all i think it's also time to release
our prisoner faviano thank you faviano
for joining us and uh hopefully we'll
see you again in the studio thank you
guys thank you fabi and
let me then take control let's go around
the horn a little bit on what we have
left
uh here in
round number one we actually have a
bunch of games left surprisingly i only
sue i only see two results so far and
we've already mentioned them chris
trapka did beat uh jj ali marandi
meanwhile ilya nishnik drew against sam
sabian on group a so let's go around the
horn real quick to see what is going on
in this game between
armand mikhailian and
assam hanin
it looks
like black is fully in control
they both made move 40 their mu 41 but
maybe i'm overestimating i hear black's
position a little bit that looks so
close to the end game between uh right
and christopher
almost the same structure almost the
same structure right but
the knight is much better placed on c4
you're not down a pawn and after the
move kings c3 you do have tactics like
knight takes a5
it's not so clear when they work
but i think that white should have
enough not to be worse in this position
i still take black i absolutely i think
i still think black is preference here
let's continue down the board we have a
fantastic
material imbalance
in the game between elsa and maria
javadi and
we have two rooks for black and two
bishops
the white has not only the queen and the
two knights but also those past pawns on
b4 and a5
i don't even know how to start
evaluating this one why why did we
release fabi
what is this
well it does seem like white definitely
is in pole position to score a victory
right now
right
those pawns look so threatening now you
have to be very careful because if i
manage somehow to open up one of the
bishops then your king gets checkmated
yeah this is a big issue right if i
managed to get the other rook on the
first rank and started attacking the
pawn on h2 the king guest check made it
yeah so you have to be extremely crafty
with white to block all of these
opportunities for black i see maybe an
idea of just simply playing the move
knight to e3 retreating with the knight
knight to e2 sorry retreating with the
knight covering up uh this penetration
of the e file but also defending the
pawn on d4 and then i'm just
i'm going to find the configuration to
play knight to b3 defend the pawn on a5
and then start pushing the pawns i like
it and also it also tries to kick out
that rook nice t5 might be a good move
and i i do wonder if at some point i'm
okay with giving up the queen and the
knight for the two rooks because these
bishops
they're not great as long for stopping
the pawns the knight will do a great job
pushing both of them
it's still a wild game it does i do
agree with you my initial impression is
it's a chaos chaotic game my second
impression i think this one is solidly
in white's hand with proper play again
the both players have reached time
control and he didn't like the move 92
but he did play another solid move
though knight e3
uh sorry knight f1 trying to go to e3
putting pressure on this pawn on f5 yeah
this looks very bad for white
let's continue
games that i haven't been able to see
abioaniu mishra is playing against titus
stramavichus and this one looks like a
draw it doesn't matter how much white
tries all black really needs to do is
keep the bishop on this diagonal and
defend this pawn on f7 you cannot kick
out the king from g7 this should be just
a very basic draw it is it is even with
an extra pawn on the file for white that
one is probably winning for white but
it's not easy and it's not always it's
not always winning yes absolutely
correct so we're going to let this one
go because it's definitely a draw we saw
the handle is very close to being uh
done and maybe we can jump to that one
is the clash between jeffrey shang uh
the rating favorite of the a group and
uh mikhail antipov because that one is
about to finish yeah we had seen the
game back here after
um
what did we leave it here here on typo
played knight d7 and it seems that the
pair of bishops eventually proved to be
too much
well that is this that's a very cute
tactic simplifying the position and a
transformation of advantages the king is
still very weak uh f6 is going to be a
checkmating thread in many variations
but
you don't even have to calculate them
that rook is taking on c5 black
that was a resignation yeah it looks
like right and that is wrestling
yeah let's go
real quick on how they got to the final
position jeffrey scores his first
victory of the tournament
giving away the pawn trying to get one
back on f5 but none of this is quite
enough that's too many pass pawns on the
on the queen side for jeffrey who scores
a very clean victory with a small idea
in the scotch game and taking it home
without any real problems the last move
rook f7 check just seals the deal
and
a very nice game here by uh
one of the top american players a
typical jeffrey win yeah gets a slight
advantage out of the opening knows the
positions better than his opponent and
uh squeezes a victory out of that yeah
let's continue with the game of camille
dragoon and dario scherz
this one another material imbalance
as you can see
black has a queen
against the two rooks but i'm trying to
count the pawns and i think black has
two points am i counting that right
black has two extra pawns black has two
extra pawns for that material imbalance
if this rook
could join the fray that'd be it this
king is getting checkmated but i'm not
really sure how this rook is ever gonna
join the fray uh to be quite honest with
you so always go rook check but that's
the question i think it's more than
perpetual let's go to that so king to h7
is the only move you cannot go king to
f7 because rook of faith would win the
queen and win the game yes so after king
h7 let's just continue with this
perpetual rook to e7 right perpetual
attempt and you were mentioning that uh
it's very difficult to find a way for
that rook to get rerouted now the
question is can black play for more
after knight to f7
because this is just a draw right i i
would be very scared as black to be
because of
e3
rookie three and finally the rook comes
into the attack yeah i don't want to do
f4
very important this night is actually
gorgeous not only does it attack but it
also defends a very critical point of
blacks of white's position which is the
f4 square is the only check that um
black has here but it's not over even in
that position is not over really because
you have queen to f6
oh always resourceful so rook to e8
right seems to be the only move let me
think unless i'm missing something no i
don't see much there i don't see a big
advantage
no actually you can do that huh king g7
king to g7 and now we're going to make a
draw right yeah e6 i think that after
the move knight f7 i'm looking for more
who's playing for a victories i have the
feeling it's white but it wouldn't it
also wouldn't surprise me that black has
quite enough i'm a little scared about
this move rook e8 i'm sorry rookie 8 and
interposing with 901. i think that black
is the one that should
reign in the position and just emit a
draw
as we do see the players repeating at
least once they have already made time
control so that's not much of an issue
king h7 rookie 7 on the board and darius
stops and thinks do i want to consider
the move knight f7 which i believe to be
a slightly crazy
but that's how my students play chess
or play the same move king
g8 and he has reached time control so of
course he'll take his time thinking
about this one i do expect the move king
j to be played i don't think that it's
white that's risking anything
but uh before we get too much into that
we do have one of the winners of today's
round jeffrey sean with a very very
clean game against mikhail antipa thank
you alejandro yes we are here with one
of the young stars of american trust
jeffrey shong after a very smooth
victory jeffrey tell us a little bit how
does it feel to be back over the board
here in saint louis
yeah
i guess it's been a while
especially for me personally uh my last
event was the uh grand swiss and riga
back in november so
yeah it's been a while just uh good to
be back really enjoying the weather so
far so yeah
tell us a little bit about this game it
felt like your typical victory you just
got a nice advantage out of the opening
with a crafty idea in this uh scottish
game tell us a little bit about that
yeah actually i wasn't sure um
how i how i handled this so let's i
guess we can uh on this one go back okay
yeah so okay yeah you can keep going
here
he was spending a lot of time were you
surprised by that
um a bit okay i saw that he had a couple
of boots games in this line but
yeah i mean i was a little bit surprised
i guess yeah
where do you think his real mistake came
so yeah i think
by the way i was wondering actually if
he takes nf3 first maybe this is a
better version like takes in bishop d4
were you out of your opening preparation
at this point
i had some ideas but maybe not in this
exact position so
yeah okay bishop uh the point is yeah if
i long castle bish b5 i think maybe this
is what
he wanted to get in the game right let's
point out why you cannot greedily
yeah here okay this is actually probably
playable but knight d5 maybe it's right
the idea you hang the knight but
remember that this bishop is now
targeting g7 and that would trap a full
rook not just uh an exchange
so well probably right i don't think the
bishop gets trapped
complicated
so black would play here
oh probably you have to take right you
have to take on d5 bishop takes g7 could
play f6 but that's pretty ugly all right
f6
yeah definitely not crystal clear but um
probably is the rook cannot go to g1
yeah this is a big issue how's it there
it's mentally readying myself to put
something on the g7 square but
you can't actually access the gym rook
takes d5 let's try to open up that
diagonal and get with the rook to h5
messy i need to help that bishop somehow
it is definitely messy but at the end of
the day on the worst case scenario
white will have two pawns
on the rook for two minor pieces no way
he's worse
yeah
so bishop d4 was played immediately
without the queen exchange and it did
feel that this end game was just very
unpleasant for the black side and
white's position more or less float
yeah yeah i i think so but at some point
i feel like um
i made a slight inaccuracy so if we uh
continue on
so yeah this
i think yeah 97 caught me by surprise
because i was expecting let's say castle
and then my idea was bishop d3
say bishop d7 seems normal and now i
want this bishop 83 to threaten knight
d2
and the bishop is kind of awkward
but he surprised me with knight d7
and i think i should now i should just
play keen c1 because he he freed up the
d5 square for my knight
i think kingsman would have been uh
simply better
but now bishop a3 i don't like this
because now he okay force him to take on
c3
but here he made a mistake so i think if
he just castles
it's not so bad for him
all right maybe even a solid move like
f6 i'm wondering
yeah f6 maybe maybe but i don't think
it's quite necessary maybe just castle's
rookie 8 and so on right
because yeah if i don't get the idea in
the game
and the idea of the game was 95 you
played f4
knight
c6 and e5 and it just seems like
position is blowing up without any real
development from black
yeah i was expecting um so yeah knight
d14 b2 i thought he was going to try
bishop e6
so that he can he can meet see through
with uh knight takes b3
yeah and this is yeah okay yeah he's
probably
doing well here
probably just to draw right
well
he will move the rook somewhere else
yeah and then somewhere else
actually even though that's not over
it's not so clear yeah because you do
have bishop d5 check at the end ah okay
picks up the right yeah it wasn't really
what i wanted
and now probably k7 and followed by rook
b8 and you can resign so bishop e6 but
yeah i think
the key idea here after bishop b6 is
king c1
so preparing um c3 again this is very
crafty right you realize this one here
here yeah
diamond kind of but yeah now if he goes
king seven i guess i taken bishop b2 so
it still
should be good for me
the bishops are roaring in this position
especially this dark squared one
difficult to defend the diagonal
yeah this looks bad for black
but actually in the game he was he found
a good way to fight on because at first
i thought it's
close to winning but
so yeah let's continue here um he played
king seven instead
and then yeah maybe i had something more
precise but i went for c3 now 96
f5 knight f8 so actually
it looks really bad but
i wasn't sure how how to uh
to break this right so you went rookie
one
king d8 rook d1 repeated once but after
bishop d3
just look
to our eyes without any engine it's
pretty clear it it's definitely better
but yeah in this position i think
uh
yeah after g4 i was more worried about
rook b6 first defending the weakness
here on d6
and then like h4h6
and it's going to be
it's a better version of the game where
he allowed tactics so
here i think it's not so easy for me and
we do have a result that one is over
between maura di abadi and uh raja
muradi abadi managed to secure the
victory yeah we're talking about that
those pawns on the queen set will show
the end of the game in a little bit but
let's finish this one up 95 did surprise
you and let's just show the tactic in
the game
bishop takes c5 a distraction here uh
for black of course it's kind of nice
that knight takes d3 inter mezzo doesn't
quite work we have this move rogue d6 at
the end and the king is caught it's not
quite checkmate but it is pretty bad as
you have to play bishop e6 losing the
piece for free
yeah i wanted to put out one more funny
idea that i saw so uh after h4
you can also try to take on d3 and rook
b6
and then i thought rook d5 threatening
mate h6
and now i can still go c4 probably
and if okay bishop b7 i can move my king
for example and still the movement it's
funny how this king is getting mated
from every angle yeah this is actually
pretty sad for black and the position in
the game equally sad
uh this just isn't lost anywhere
pointing out the weaknesses on the queen
side no real development to help them
out a very clean victory jeffrey thanks
congratulations uh jeffrey and uh well
hopefully we're going to see you again
here in the studio in the next few years
i hope so as well
all right let's take a look at the end
of that game between uh elsia moriarty
body and roger harshit we did leave it
in what initially looked like a complex
position but the more we delved into it
over by this position
that these pawns were just going to roll
down the board and indeed they did
knight f1 was a nice move to reroute to
e3 christian like a knight e2 but i
think it is just a choice of riches rook
e4 looks a bit too desperate for my
liking yes you do remove one of the
knights but i don't actually see what it
accomplishes because the queen can stay
on c4 and it does defend the pawn on d4
and the queen's coming here and the
queen is coming here and yeah this is
absolutely
falling apart for black
it's such a tease to have those
beautiful bishops yeah but not be able
to actually get them involved into the
game because that pawn on e4 blocking
one of the bishops the pawn on d4 nicely
protected by the queen blocking the
other bishop this one is such a sad
situation for white but another sad
situation for white
is in the game between hans niemann and
ray robson oh and we were having our
eyes on for a very long time
hans was completely dominating
throughout the middle game
but then he just allowed robson back
into the game allowed himself to get
back to those
very critical last couple of minutes on
the clock and he just simply did not
make the best decisions and right now
he's finding himself in a very difficult
situation we see
this move we left it off at uh move
number 40 immediately as they reached
the time control with this move queen to
f6 and fabian also was saying that this
is starting to become quite unpleasant
for white because
it all comes down to whose king is safer
and right now it seems like i have more
pieces closer to yorking as black i'm
ready to go knight to f3 of course that
would uh close the match in one move you
have to defend against that but the
coordination between the queen and the
knight against
a naked king like this on g1 well it's
just extremely difficult to defend
against and we see that the pressure is
on right now we see this move queen to
e3 knight to c4 queen to d3 queen to a1
is uh not yet on the board so this is
the position right now that we have
queen to d3 was played ray robson 23
minutes
calculating right now how do i get to
his king well it seems like the most
straightforward way to get there is with
the move queen to a1 that makes a lot of
sense of course you see a check
you give the check that's how we play
chess maybe not power but that's how we
play chess
of course queen to a1 well what if he
goes king to g2 now you're going to
continue giving checks of course we know
you see a check you give it king to h3
and now of course you're not going to
hurry up with capturing the pawn on b4
because
this would be a huge mistake it would
allow the move queen to d4 which simply
finishes the game in white's favor you
cannot block this diagonal with a move
knight to e5 because the queen on b4 is
hanging queen takes b4 would be a huge
critical mistake but what you can do is
just simply reverse the order of the
moves you're actually going to block
this diagonal first with the knight
knight to e5 now wherever the move uh
wherever white is going to move the
queen i'm just simply going to take on
b4 and actually the knight is ready to
defend the king we were mentioning uh in
uh this game particularly but earlier in
the game that the knights next to the
king are extremely protective and this
is exactly what we see right now if you
try to do this i can go d5 first of all
open up uh this file for the root and
potentially give a check didn't work
last last move maybe it's just at one
point right now d5 right here king h3 d5
immediately
i want to play
now i have rook to c6 and the knight is
not on e5 defending that square c6
computer so so close very crafty yeah
yeah you have to be very careful with a
knight forward b5 actually works for
white
like rick sees no no they're 95. d5
first yes because i was thinking d5
rook c6 what if i play 95 here but
somehow queen takes b5 keeps everything
oh queen takes precisely
d5 and now i'm just going to play this
ah and the king is yeah this becomes
your position is still better as black
but i no longer have this knight
protecting my king my king is a bit weak
and it seems like it's enough
compensation for the exchange i can
imagine the knight coming to d4 and f5
certainly so continue that line 95 first
very accurate i like it and then when
you cannot play the rook to c6 the queen
has to go somewhere so what if you take
on b5 right it seems like you're getting
closer questions uh queen that's a very
critical question well the problem is
this knight coming to f3
i'm coordinating and getting ready to
checkmate you
also i'm defending the g5 square that's
a beautiful move this would be a
checkmate in one move that's a beautiful
move knight f3 but the knight on f3
protects that and that just finishes the
game let's see what happens if you take
the rook where is the checkmate well i'm
just simply going to take king to g4
knight goes back to e5 king to f4 or f5
queen to f2 king to g5 queen to f6 is
probably a checkmate h6 getting the
queen on the h-file followed by queen to
h2 that's also a checkmate it just seems
like well first of all black has to see
this black has to understand this but he
does have a lot of time to think about
it he's going to calculate we know that
robson is a very very good calculator
he spends his time wisely and even when
he gets in time pressure as he did in
this game he's going to create programs
for his opponent all the way until the
end and we see that hans was just unable
to keep the pace with the complications
that were happening on the board yeah
he's going to kick himself for missing
that opportunity earlier of knight takes
d6 instead of recapturing the bottom
before the engines i did go back to see
it did give him a winning advantage
we're analyzing that variation with
fabiano caruana let's go back into this
position a crucial problem here after
pawn takes before do you play the
seemingly simple a takes before which
allowed a surprising counter play with
the move rook c2 especially since the
a-file is now open for the rook or do
you go for the complications with knight
takes d6 hunts made the wrong choice on
this turn of course the game wasn't over
by any means by after that but
it is clear that things went very wrong
for him
hard didn't really understand exactly
where they went wrong probably this move
probably this move queen e3 if i had to
guess here fabiano was mentioning
the details between queen c3 and queen
e3 that you had to pick one of them but
he wasn't sure which one
and the more i look at it the more i
think the move queen c3 was more
accurate simply because you retained
control over this long diagonal and you
can see how it's abandoning this
diagonal with the move queen e3 that
might bite
hands back because queen a1 queen b to
95 this reconfiguration of black pieces
looks very compelling
just play that move queen to c3 oh yes
queen c3 i'll show you a very uh nice
move rook to a8
[Laughter]
sometimes i love computers sometimes
usually 99.9 of the time i hate
computers rook a8
beautiful move rook takes a8 not
possible because knight f3 check
and then you pick up the queen this must
have been what kind of scared hans away
from this position there yeah i start to
see how this gets dangerous right right
ca knight d3 is a little bit of a threat
it just feels like everything becomes a
little bit of a threat maybe the error
became came even earlier it's hard to
say but before we delve into it let us
join our guest in the studio he also won
his game today el shan maria de body
with a very nice victory
another victor after a very tense game
is indeed here with us alejandro elshaan
welcome to the studio what a game take
us a little bit through that and take us
a little bit uh about your feelings of
returning to saint louis and playing
once again over the board chess
well it was a very good feeling winning
the first round this is actually now
with this one playing spring classics i
play all four seasons so this is the
first time for me completed the seasons
so it feels good to be here playing
chess and uh i haven't played much in
2020 and nothing in 2020 and very few
games in 2021
so feels great to be here playing one
game a day it's always a great treat and
pleasure being being here and this is
the first time i also win my first round
game so it couldn't be a better start
huh it feels like that was the reality
for most of us not playing too much
chess in 2020 and 2021 but uh now we're
back over at the board take us through
this game uh el shawn sure actually
wasn't a very good game but let's look
at it absolutely here it is up on the
board okay
take us to the critical position yeah
e6
uh uh well i didn't expect bishop v7
actually so i was out of my prep because
he always plays almost
exclusively c6 here so
i just when i play bishop e7 relatively
quickly i just thought okay let's play
old school chess so play bishop g5
castle rook c1 so cop of course powerful
stuff
and h6 bishop h4
b6 e3
6 f6 takes cd this is goes back carp of
karpov uh
spassky match 1973 or 74. semi-final of
the world championship
all right
so let's keep going this
and here after this i messed up i think
here i messed up i play knight d2
i think i should go knight d1
because rerun if he goes f5 i can go f4
later and put the knight back on e5
you're much faster yeah yeah
that's why i was worse after i mean i
don't know if i have it right away
because he has queen e7 now but if we
did the right prep i can't go knight d3
f4 95. so because my plan is always
bishop on f3 g3 bishop comes in the
knight d3 then i want to go back queen
c2 before right i mean you guys are
better than me
so
i played actually this plant in two was
roger harshly born in 2005
he was pretty young but he was
definitely born because i'm the oldest
player in that whole tournament
it's i am the oldest player so it feels
very
special it's the first time i'm the
oldest player in the whole hull and you
were mentioning that on one of your
posts uh on facebook yeah yeah this is
the first time i am the one how does
that feel
it feels odd
you're still quite young
so when i play rpmania he i'm three
times his age and i play mania he's like
three times his age
but where's the three times the rating
right yeah
yeah
uh i need to get that there too so you
want to go back to the game let's go
back to the game okay
so yeah i think now i'm probably screwed
up if you run engine i'm probably
slightly worse here already so i just
try to just
muster up something g3 this bishop d3
g5 and i was very happy of seeing this
move that was not a good move i was sure
because after this move over q1 g5 now
queen city doesn't have queen g6 because
of g4 i think he missed you for here
because if i go f4 i would he would play
queen g6 there and then instead of
rookie instead of uh queen c2 if i play
f4 he has queen g6 and now he takes f4
now you don't have king
one and that's the temple here yes yeah
because of this problem right where
you're taking it again it's a pin okay
so
queen c2
and queen e6 then i play a force i
thought okay probably i equalized here
now g4 because he has to blow g
otherwise knight is coming back the
difference of a tempo right yeah yeah so
he has to go g4 oh this is bad okay
um can i play a3
actually if i remember correctly uh i
was checking this position with the
engine the engine's moves uh was h3 i
should consider that yeah i consider h3
takes
knight f3 right is that i don't remember
what the computer g8 and i was i wasn't
sure what to do here because queen f3
takes rook g3 maybe king two h2 what's
the knight f6 a knight to f6 is coming
with uh tempo knight to g4 oh my
goodness i was i was like
takes f5 no no he doesn't play right
there but he goes with af8 first and
then knight f6
but does that have is that a threat
no that doesn't help right i'm not going
to take on h3 maybe i can go knight wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
uh i saw this can we go back for a
second please sorry of course take on h3
rook g8 h2 uh queen g6 first
okay
rook g1
yeah uh knight f6 now maybe no but i
still take on f5 and that means g4 king
h1 is nothing let me just show this oh
yes no but i can simply also just take
on the g for you
because you know i saw actually there's
a nice line there
i i think maybe too much analyzing this
position because h3 if he goes h5 i know
i don't know if i calculate correctly hg
now i have e4 because after all the
captures they'll have a queen h2 at the
end
oh my god where'd this come from
do i have it can we check with the
engine or something if i have
does it work i mean i don't usually use
it yeah it works you've got the
inclusion of the edge file because now
after 94 i have 96 queen h2 and you're
actually checkmating so i saw that that
that this must work but then gtx h3 i
couldn't figure out ah it would have
been it felt right but i couldn't see
entirely through it but you played a5
which felt right as well because you're
trying to expand on the queen
yeah block that bishop on b7 there's no
more c5 coming yeah if i i mean i was
surprised that i played knight a4 i was
trying to make sure he never played c5
because if he doesn't play c5 i'm okay
i've it was bad probably it was with
lots of temporary one
and then
yeah that was
that was a shocker big shocker and after
bishop b5 then then we get shaker with
cd4 i didn't see that one coming at all
well it wasn't a good move
that's what happens takes on d4 so he
gave up
takes and then king after rookie seven
now critical i think bishop d7 is bad
right
so explain to us why e8 is not good can
you explain to us why rook fe8 is not
good doubling up
e8 uh
because v2 is covered now i think on f5
you can just simply take one f yeah yeah
so don't take on d7 that would be a
checkmate in one move
but you simply take on f5 yeah that's
just falling apart for black right yeah
i spent 20 minutes 15 minutes here and
all my gut feelings was saying i have to
go bishop d3 and i still played bishop
xd7 well to be fair the engine move is
knight c3
[Music]
don't feel too bad
uh
yeah bishop d3 just uh to to spare you
uh is not as good as bishop takes d7 ah
okay so okay so if those were your two
options you got it right
all right okay so i took on d7
probably i'm somewhat better
uh plus three plus three wow okay so i i
was like it must be winning but it's a
long way but three plus three okay but
it's an engine i should have taken there
again huh
yeah don't worry about those
those uh question marks they don't
matter too much yeah in a practical game
okay knight b6 rook
e7
i will go very fast yeah rookie seven
then i think ricky is a mistake because
he had to go bishop a6 to cover so
rookie eight and then
idea and then the knights should be
winning now i'd say three and
then sorry the queen d3 and then after
that i i don't know if i ever blundered
you want to go faster if i belong any
time pressure oh
didn't see that one made a mistake it's
king g6 i just went to grab material in
time you keep missing many wins huh
no no it just thinks that
you know it's it thinks that plus four
and plus three you know it's not the
strongest engine so it doesn't have the
okay any sophistication so here i
started feeling a little bit worried uh
if i a4 is a mistake or not
oh major do i let go of the win or still
winning
do you want the truth
i i felt i felt i i blundered yeah it
doesn't like it it says it's 0.6 because
of maybe bishop d6 yeah
i i felt it yeah yeah but that's such a
natural move why didn't why did he play
bishop to a7 yeah right now i was
feeling
do i is it winning after a5 now yeah
it's completely winning and now once i
play five i was yeah because not b5 v6
is coming there is no defense against
that and uh
he played okay one but now it's move 40
so i simply found knight the fun fight
i'm rerouting and i really like this
move knight f1 and it's just falling
apart it's funny this bishop on a7 is
we're kind of
we love these bishops next to each other
right they seem so powerful but they're
actually both blocked they're not doing
anything yeah exactly that's why i was
so surprised with ccd4 because this
structure is really against the bishops
they don't do anything yeah absolutely
you definitely evaluated this better
than your opponent in a roller coaster a
bit of a game but at the end uh wind
secured also thanks for joining us if
you're having me in the studio no of
course of course that's a great
entertaining game i hope i'll manage to
show up more often by winning some more
games you gotta you gotta show those
kids
all right also let's take a look
specking of kids of what's going on in
the okay the abi manu game is definitely
going to be a draw if we can just take a
look at that you can see that there's
not a lot of material left and the
bishop on e6 will certainly hold on
unless it doesn't matter how much white
tries on this one
this bishop is going to hold on to that
position all right we're going to leave
that as a dead draw uh let's finish up
group b this is the game between uh
mikhail and hanin and
it feels like white made five moves in a
row
this rook was here right out of nowhere
out of nowhere and this rook somehow
teleported all the way down to a7
but black did take the pawn on f4
i don't know who i prefer on this race
it does feel like white is a little bit
ahead especially with that pawn on a4
also with the fact that after i pick up
the pawn on a5
most likely you're going to have to give
a check because first of all your knight
is under attack yeah it's understandable
you're using another tempe important
tempi yeah
that being said i don't have a good
square for my king i don't really don't
want to go back
i'm going to be passing it's a big
question which side are you going to go
to right are you going to try to go
towards the king side to defend against
the expansion of black spawns or are you
going to try to support your own pawns
on the queen side the problem is that if
i do go this way right i would have to
go to d2 which i don't like yes
yeah maybe this is the way
but the thing i don't like about white's
position is that my pawn pushes are not
obvious to me i would have to first move
the rook then push the a pawn whereas i
think f5 comes with a lot of tempe on
the other hand the other side of the
story this game on g7 exactly really far
away from the action and it can start
warming up to white's chances this is a
double-edged game you might analyze this
with an engine and i mean probably we
will be throwing zeroes but we're not
engines and it these are scary end games
for both sides and they're very the
other game which is very similar to that
this one is the one between hungary and
christopher you absolutely and what oh
what is going on another pawn race but
in this one i certainly believe
in uh in black's chances simply because
you have a past h pawn it might not be
passed right now but you start to
calculate the move g5 you start to
calculate the move h4 following it up
yes you're gonna pick up a5 but are you
on time
my gut instinct is that not even close i
think g5 should be a winning move here
knight takes a5 i'll just go h4
i don't think that i don't think
i don't think hungaski has any chance of
actually saving this one there might be
a couple of tricks here and there that
i'm missing but
this looks straightforward to me i think
this point just rolls
and meanwhile let's take a look at the
superb game that we have still with us
this game between hans niemann and ray
robson let's see
where we left it off
uh
knight c4 queen d3 and we're expecting
queen a1 check
followed by
queen b2 and only when the queen was on
b2 then start playing around with the
moves d5 or knight e5 and d5 to secure
the rook coming into the attack
robson played it immediately actually he
decided to open up the rook first and we
were talking quite a lot about this
position because it's so complex there's
so many ways in which you can play it
and the move orders is so crucial so
crucial absolutely so what do we have
pawn takes d5
queen check and a big difference in this
position i've already taken this pawn on
the d5 square which gives me a
strategical advantage in any end game so
i'm very happy to trade those queens off
queen f1 plate queen d4 check queen f2
queen d1 check
i don't
see as mishra has finally given up that
draw against titus i don't
really see
black's advantage i might be missing
something but the constant threat of
taking on c4 and simplifying the
position
unless there's a killer blow that i'm
missing
maybe queen to d4 i don't think there's
any killer blow i still think black has
the edge and they have played queen d4
queen as well into f2 and maybe now i
can pick up that pawn finally on a d5
because you no longer have any sort of
uh checks at least i don't spot them so
what if i just simply take on d5
all right or maybe knight to e3 wait
wait wait wait wait okay let's try to go
knight to e3 knight e3 threatening to
move
f6
right i don't know all right
sorry no no queen d1 is one it's
definitely a threat yeah
so what do we do here
and i think this is what robson is
probably looking at
so you cannot go knight to b3 because of
queen d1 if you go rook to c1 yeah rook
c1 brings down the rook but it is a
little passive i'm slightly concerned
about with the move rook f6 rook f6 and
now let's try to find some sort of
knight to b3 maybe
b3 would be a miracle defense i have to
say knight to b3 and now my idea is if
you go if you try to keep your queen on
that diagonal on a7 g1 diagonal if you
go queen b6 maybe rook to c6
hello again alejandro hi christian good
to have you here
it was a long walk all the way back to
the to the desk surprise surprise
surprise surprise uh let us take a look
uh i'm gonna cheat a little bit because
we do have a lot of results coming in
that the move 93 is no good queen takes
d5 does rese does preserve some chances
for black
but knight e3
forces the move rook c1 we have looked
at that
rook f6 and
uh let's hit engines again apparently
knight b3 does work
knight to b3 as well as knight c6
somehow still
holding on to the position it's
difficult to believe but tactics are
tactics
well we have a lot of resources just go
back real quick on what has happened
today
in group b
we have four out of five results uh
jeffrey sorry group a let's start with
that one jeffrey shong is so far the
only winner
of the day having defeated michelle
antipov hans niemann is currently
defending a tough position against ray
robson that is not going to be an easy
task for the rising star alex slenderman
drew his game against aramha
uh camille dragoon oh so he did defend
that actually that one plus an end game
camil dragoon did take that draw against
dario schwertz in the position with the
queen against the two rooks and in the
anishnik i'm gonna say survived a tough
position against assam savian
meanwhile in group b uh we also have
four out of those what we actually have
more results than that let's just go
through them real quick
uh we have uh the games of christopher
repka and el shamura their body both
with the white pieces defeating jj
alimorandi and harshid raja respectively
we still have the game of christopher
you going and we still do have the game
of michalyan against conning going we
expect that one to be close to a draw
but still a very sharp one and we do
have a result in abhimanyu versus titus
that one finished in a draw
but once again we see a black uh has had
a pretty difficult round the only
victory in group a well white one that
one and now we see right now on the
screen two victories four the white
pieces in group b as well what do you
think about that
i think that ray rosso might still have
a say on that one as he is the one
pressing with the black pieces there but
certainly not a good day for
black it seemed
not necessarily related to the opening
in many cases but the white was able to
impose in many positions very tense
battle in that one and we saw some very
crafty ideas we saw that move g5 by
black trying to take advantage of the
solidity of the king with those knights
next to it that was a very interesting
idea that i would definitely present to
my students i would assume you were
going to do the same alejandro what a
day what a day i think it's a very
interesting tournament you see the type
of chess that we have here at the 25 and
2600 level it's not quite the elite we
see in many ways lots of mistakes that
elite wouldn't make but still the
complexity the understanding the
subtleties the calculation it's all
there it just shows how strong chess
players have become
we're going to be signing off here but
remember you can still follow the
remaining games on uschesschamps.com and
tomorrow well we're going to meet again
at 3 30. don't forget the game starts at
1pm central time but we're going to
start our show a little bit later in the
hit of the battle at 3 30 p.m and until
then well we're signing off i'm grand
master christian carrillo his
grandmaster alejandro ramirez and we're
going to see you guys tomorrow pleasure
to be here see you tomorrow
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited